let's see if we can find the cube root
of 3430
and if you're like me it doesn't jump
out of of out of your mind what number
times that same number times that same
number if you have three of those
numbers and you were to multiply them
together would be equal to 34 30. so
what i'm going to do is to try to prime
factorize this to find all the prime
factors of
3430 and see if any of those prime
factors show up at least three times and
that'll help us with this so 3430
it's clearly divisible by five and two
so or it's divisible by 10. so let's do
that so first we can divide it by two
it's two times
let's see thirty three thousand four
hundred thirty divided by two is one
thousand seven hundred and fifteen then
we can divide it by
five as well we can factor one thousand
seven hundred fifteen into five and let
me do a little bit of long division on
the side here so if i 1715
and i'm gonna divide it by five
five doesn't go into one it goes into 17
three times three times five is fifteen
subtract
you get two
and then you bring down a one
five goes into 21 four times four times
five is 20. subtract
bring down the five
five goes into 15 three times so it goes
exactly 343 times
so 1715 can be factored into 5
times 343.
now 343 might not jump out at you as a
number that is easy to factor it's
clearly an odd number so it won't be
divisible by two its digits add up to
ten which is not divisible by three so
this isn't going to be divisible by
three it's not going to be divisible by
four because it's not divisible by two
it's not going to be divisible by five
if it wasn't divisible by three or two
it's not gonna and it's not going to be
divisible by six
and now we get to seven and seven
usually when you see kind of a nutty
number like this that doesn't seem to be
divisible by a lot of things it's always
a good idea to try things like 7 11 13
because those tend to construct very
interesting numbers so let's see if this
is divisible by 7.
so if i take 343
and if i want to divide it by 7
seven goes into 30 doesn't go to three
seven goes into 34
four times four times seven is 28
subtract 34 minus 28 is six
bring down a three
7 goes into 63 9 times 9 times 7 is 63
subtract we don't have any remainder and
i forgot to do that last step up here 3
times 15 is 15 subtract no remainder
went in exactly so here 343 can be
factored into 7
and 49
and 49 and 49 might jump out at you it
can be factored into 7
times
7.
so this is interesting i can rewrite all
of this here the cube root of 3430 now
as
the cube root
the cube root of
i'm just going to write it in its
factored form two times five
times i could write seven times seven
times seven or i could write times seven
to the third power
times seven to the third power that
captures these three sevens right over
here i have three sevens and then i'm
multiplying them together so that's
seven to the third power
and from our exponent properties we know
that this is the exact same thing this
is the exact same thing as the cube root
the cube root of
two times 5
times
times the cube root so let me do that
same
just so we see what colors we're dealing
with so the cube root of 2 times 5 which
is the cube root of 10
times
times the cube root
and i think you see where this is going
cube root of 7 to the third power
7 to the third power keeping track of
the colors is the hard part
7 to the third power
and the cube root of 10 we just leave it
as 10 we know the prime factorization of
10 is 2 times 5 so you're not going to
just get a very simple integer answer
here you would get some decimal answer
here but here you get a very clear
integer answer the cube root of 7 to the
third well that's just going to be 7. so
this is just going to be 7. so our
entire thing simplifies this is equal to
times the cube root
cube root
of
10. this is about as simplified as we
can get just using hand arithmetic if
you want to get the exact the exact
number here
you're probably best off using a
calculator